de la course à pied du golf du radeau ou
encore du vtt six épreuves pour ce
onzième trophée des entreprises sur un
parcours de plus de 7 km au coeur de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines un défi éprouvant si tu sais je
pense qu'à la fin il fallait inverser en
courant c'était un peu casse gueule
le radeau physique
les épreuves des grands groupes des pme
ou les services de communes du
territoire de nombreuses équipes venues
avec leurs supporters pour porter les
valeurs du sport et de l'entreprise les
valeurs du sport c'est bien sûr être le
meilleur mais en même temps il ya
beaucoup de sport d'équipé où là il faut
pas être seulement le meilleur il faut
être celui qui apporte le plus de valeur
ajoutée au groupe est en fait on
retrouve cette logique aujourd'hui de
donc elle est dans l'entreprise
à quelques mois de la ryder cup cette
édition du trophée des entreprises
avaient enfilé les couleurs de la
compétition mondiale de golf